last video we end with the conquests of
alexander the great how he's able to
conquer
most of the map that we see right up
here especially from
greece all the way through
the middle east through persia and
getting to the borders of india
conquering north cove conquering egypt
as well and we mentioned that he had a
very short life and after his death his
empire was split but coincident with
that time we have other powers in other
parts of the mediterranean that are
growing namely the romans
and rome was established several hundred
years before the time of alexander the
great but by that time they're starting
to conquer more and more of the italian
peninsula right over here what we would
now consider the italian peninsula you
also have a power in carthage
in carthage forming right over here on
the north african coast carthage was
initially a
a phoenician settlement the phoenicians
famous for our phonetic alphabet the
phoenicians were based in what is now
modern-day lebanon and syria and they
were traitors and they settled
throughout the mediterranean and
carthage and the carthaginian
power or or civilization was a fairly
significant one at this time and you can
imagine when there are two powers that
are close to each other and they might
want to be going after the same
interests or conquest the same land or
they might view each other as a threat
they tend to start fighting each other
and that is true of rome and carthage
and the wars that they fought they were
called the punic wars and they occurred
between 264
bce
and 146
you have the punic wars
punic
and once again we will do many videos on
the punic wars but these are the wars
that involved hannibal famously taking
elephants across the alps in order to
attack rome and we see it right over
here on our little timeline the punic
wars between carthage and rome and just
to be clear
this little purple
is shaded in on our timeline that
represents the
carthage and the carthaginian
civilization i guess you say power and
this is rome
but eventually rome wins decisively and
is actually able to wipe out carthage
literally wipe it out and so rome more
and more is because it was becoming the
dominant uh the dominant power in the
mediterranean and as we will see shortly
well beyond the mediterranean
in this period
rome is a republic and when we talk
about a republic we're talking about
some type of
representation although it's not the
same form of representation that we
would think today
we would be talking about some form of
preserving rights once again not exactly
as we would do today but as we get to
the middle of the first century bce we
have a roman a very successful roman
general you might have heard his name
julius caesar who is able to take power
of rome who is able to be the dictator
of rome and in power he
starts to end the republic and he does
many other things he starts rearranging
the calendar gets a month named after
him july
and then he gets assassinated and his
adopted son augustus takes power and
augustus is often considered to be the
first true emperor of rome that the
republic is now over and he too gets a
month named after him
august
now at around the same time you have
another very significant figure that
shows up and obviously jesus is a
significant figure in religion
but that has effect on history his
teachings are the basis of a religion
that's going to have profound
consequences for the rest of history for
the world
and even though we might have this you
could say the secular timeline of bce or
first before the common era or ce the
common era right now the year i'm making
this video is 2016 ce those are secular
versions of a calendar which is
essentially centered on jesus's birth or
pretty close to jesus's birth instead of
bc if it would be before christ instead
of c e would say a a d in the year of
our lord in latin and jesus it's
important to note because sometimes
people might learn about the life of
jesus and they might think about the
holy land and nazareth and jerusalem and
whatever else but it's important to
realize that at that time this was jesus
was born and raised and grew up and died
as part of the roman empire in fact when
he was born which wasn't actually zero
bce or zero we should just say year zero
we now think that was pretty close to
four bce or four bc
so he was born in the reign of augustus
and he died in the reign of tiberius so
some of the first roman emperors so with
that we have our overview of especially
ain't civil ancient civilization and in
the next few videos or many videos we
will go deeper and go and drill deep
into each of these topics that we
referred to but hopefully the last video
just give you a a high level view of
what was happening in the world both in
terms of time and space